[Music]
cassidy with the best friends in his
corner
yeah back intercepts pack's not
uh it'll get in a good mood cassidy with
the waist lock
switch
back wondering where that came from
there you go orange rolling away
[Applause]
that's the only thing he could do you're
right that's why they call him the king
of sloth style
look at his back the mark's on his back
already from this
all right
i love it oh
there's a very effective counter ladies
and gents
he dodged two bullets and seemingly it's
all he's got right now
they look at him he can't even get up
over the floor
[Applause]
crackers cassidy
[Applause]
that's getting really frustrating he's
searching
around the ring oh cassie smiles
darby allen perhaps taking out a
competition for good sammy says i'm
crazy
oh my god
absolutely amazing mystery entrant
[Applause]
won't be a mister much longer
[Applause]
darby who can stop the path
of cage
wow how about this
[Music]
being accompanied to the ring by tazz
[Music]
omega what are we doing here with sami
oh no
oh god of heaven good lord the one
winged angel
i wouldn't do that hardy
stop right there this superhero becomes
a ghost story
i've mentored you and you showed me no
loyalty
i was sammy's first mentor he's loyal
all the time i choose sammy every day
every time over
[Music]
darby one two cody counters again two
darby one two one oh my god
oh my god
are you kidding me
these fans here they're going absolutely
crazy
in support of darby allen
cody rhodes let darby hang around for
too
long
look at the size difference
and look at the new face of tnt
fans chanting you deserve it you're damn
right they do
he does
well there you see it ladies and
gentlemen
the brand new tnt champion
his name is darby allen and yes he is a
strange
enigma but right now today
he's the face of tnt